this video is brought to you by audible
they're offering cold fusion fans a free
audio book and
30 day trial audible has an unmatched
selection of audio books
and it's great for people like me that
don't have time to sit down and read a
book
right now i'm reading ready player one
it's a great science fiction work
based on a dystopian world where vr is
the basis of society
it was written in 2011 before the second
explosion of vr and it's fascinating to
take a look at some insights from in
there
i have some big plans for the future of
this channel that will be made possible
by sponsors like audible and you so if
you want to support the channel
and get a free audio book in the process
go to audible.com
coldfusion that's audible.com
c-o-l-d-f-v after you sign up
check out ready player one and let me
know what you guys think in the comments
you are watching cold fusion tv
[Applause]
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
today youtube is the single biggest
disruptor of video media on earth
from independent small films to news
media and entirely new genres of
programming
when youtube started it was truly
something different from anything that
had come before it
it was all in the name the you in
youtube was in reference to the producer
and the aim was to broadcast yourself
this theme was highlighted in 2006
when time magazine's person of the year
was you
the caption on the cover read yes you
you control the information age
welcome to your world and this was
entirely true
in the beginning we had the power to
turn youtube into anything that we
wanted
one of the most popular sites on the
internet is youtube is where people all
over the world post their homemade
videos from
anybody to see they had 60 000 clips a
day get millions of hits
but recently some people don't feel the
same way some say that the true essence
of youtube has been diluted with
corporate interests
coupled with drama and demonetization
running rampant
but today in this video we'll just focus
on youtube
its size and some fascinating insights
into how it's changed our world
this is going to be a pretty interesting
video let's get straight into it
youtube was started by three ex-paypal
employees
chad hurley steve chen and joad crim
the year was 2005 and it was an
interesting time
there was no such thing as a smartphone
as we know it today
rap and rnb were in but so was emo and
post hardcore
and the cgi in movies was just starting
to become okay
one day in 2005 the trio realized that
it was hard to find a copy of janet
jackson's wardrobe malfunction that
occurred in the 2004 super bowl
this problem sparked an idea there had
to be an easier way to upload and share
videos
they knew the technology existed it was
just a matter of building the right
website to take advantage of it
so they did it was a really small team
to begin with
just a group of a few guys who thought
it would be a really awesome project
to give you some idea of how small the
team really was we we basically had
two sets admins more or less two
software architects dealing with
scalability issues
we had two featured developers doing
everything that the users see
we had two network engineers building a
network that pushed tens of gigabits per
second
and one dba and and we hadn't been
bought by google's and no chefs yet
and if you think i'm kidding about the
drinking or sleeping parts
and nope
was such an awesome project that google
took notice just one year later in 2006
google would buy youtube
fast forward to today and now the
website is a totally new world of
sharing video content on a massive
global scale
never seen before so the question must
be asked
how big is youtube every minute
400 hours of video are uploaded it's an
ocean of images and sound
offering all kinds of experiences
imaginable
38 of users are female and 62
are male 1.3 billion people around the
world use youtube
in 2006 this was just 20 million
together these 1.3 billion people watch
5 billion videos per day
every day 1 billion hours are watched on
youtube with half of these views coming
from mobile devices
so 1 billion hours sounds kind of
meaningless but let's break it down to
give you an idea of just how massive
that is
it's over 100 000 years of video content
or
15 times the amount of time left
throughout all of recorded history
in video format every single day
the site gets 30 million visitors per
day and 80
of that is outside of the united states
youtube is the second biggest search
engine behind google
and the third most visited site on the
internet behind google and facebook
fun fact gangnam style actually broke
youtube when it crossed
2.14 billion views in 2013. that number
was the highest integer that the 32-bit
view counter could handle
so it had to be upgraded now youtube can
support over nine quadrillion views per
video
as early as 2012 youtube was already
larger than cable tv in the united
states to put the final nail on the
coffin
in march of 2017 youtube launched
youtube tv
a direct take on cable tv at a slightly
cheaper cost than the competition
for 35 a month users get over 40 cable
channels but also can see related
youtube content
for example reactions and commentary on
a recently screened episode of a show
youtube tv is only available in selected
areas of the united states at the time
of recording this video
the average viewing session for youtube
in 2016 was 40 minutes
a 50 increase over 2015. a large part of
this is due to youtube's recommendation
algorithm
which i admit gets me stuck on
discovering new things for hours at a
time
but also a lot of this growth has come
from so-called developing nations
according to the international
telecommunications union
in 2000 for every three internet users
in a developed country
there was only one internet user in a
developing country
today it's switched for every one
internet user in a developed country
there's now two users in developing
countries all this new access to the
internet
means more access to youtube
so how does youtube work youtube's main
cost comes from the bandwidth
hardware and power consumption of their
servers
even since 2007 it was revealed by early
google programmers
that each video was hosted by a mini
cluster server
so the advantages of using a mini
cluster is as follows
one there's more disks serving content
which means more speed
two redundancy if one machine goes down
another one can take over and three
there are online backups
so how's youtube influence society so we
know some of the biggest stars have
gotten their start on youtube
these include regrettably justin bieber
or not so much
donald glover from derek comedy melanie
will you marry me no
the girls from broad city all the boys
from workaholics
and in the reverse it's now common to
see familiar faces like the rock
terry crews and stevo do collabs with
bigger youtubers
in a way this shows that youtube and
traditional film may be starting to have
a crossover
i find this really interesting but let's
go deeper than all of that
what's the real impact youtube has had
on society in 2010
the owner of ted talks chris anderson
noted that crowd accelerated learning
from youtube could dramatically
accelerate knowledge
resulting in the biggest learning cycle
in human history
perhaps that hasn't happened just yet
but i do know that i've learnt a great
deal of skills
like video editing for example just from
watching tutorials on youtube
and i'm sure some of you can relate to
that it's also common for youtube videos
to be shown in schools and universities
around the globe
watching what we want when we want in an
individualist nature is a fairly new
concept
the vhs and audio cassette recorders
were the earliest form of individualist
media consumption
youtube in a way is the next step to
this concept
we no longer need to record just find
the video and press
play the videos are archived forever
ready for us to access
for the first time mankind has a digital
video archive of our society
both from the point of view of
individuals and our culture in general
however this archiving goes even before
youtube's inception in 2005.
as i described in my other video about
youtube since 2013
there's been an increasing phenomena of
people posting vhs video recordings of
old tv shows
news music videos and anything from the
80s and 90s
this nostalgia wave has become so
apparent that one of the most
interesting sites i've come across has
spawned from it
there's actually three sites dedicated
to 70s 80s and 90s video content
they're called my 70s my 80s and my 90s
tv.com
it's basically a website where you can
look at the world through a particular
decade with the power to shuffle through
years
it's kind of the same as if you're a
couch potato just sitting and watching
tv all day
during that particular year mark's a
little sensitive about
his material
why i give up there is no way
a guy charged with theft possession of
drugs and abuse of
services after robbing a 7-eleven
shaking down a cable repairman
and several other incidents
it's just like show off what you can do
right yeah exactly and you can have a
really impressive screensaver now
on your desktop if you want now i can
also press a magical button here
the m key and voila not only can you
have stills
but you can put video in there as well
all right gizmo's 98
and uh 25 apps 50 bucks absolutely
very impressive thank you all right
that's our look at windows 98 etc i'll
be back in just a minute with my
flickaboo
all of the content on the tv of that
site is powered by youtube vhs videos
i actually find it's really interesting
to take a look at history
not filtered through any lens you can
really draw some interesting
observations that way
youtube isn't just cats vloggers and
viral videos anymore the platform is
starting to grow out of that and it's
becoming a real challenge to the old
media power structure
for example a youtuber such as philip
defranco could break a news story and
get millions of people informed without
the need for traditional media
established news outlets don't really
like this because it's costing them
subscriptions
and money and they'll use any excuse to
taint the brand image of youtube
this brings us to the recent controversy
between the mainstream media
and the new media on youtube the rivalry
was always bubbling
but really exploded in early 2017 when
youtuber pewdiepie was unfairly
misrepresented as a racist nazi by the
wall street journal and friends
these news organizations reported a
clear parody as truth
for clickbait for a bit of context of
why this might have happened we have to
look at this through the eyes of the
mainstream media
they're losing money and viewership
directly to youtube
but the most important thing that
they're losing is trust
most of the general public can feel that
the media isn't always telling the whole
truth about things
and with statements like this i guess
it's no wonder why
the the economy worsens he could have
undermined
the messaging so much that he can
actually control
exactly what people think and that is
the that is
after this there was of course the famed
advertiser boycott in march of 2017.
in the middle of march of 2017 reports
began surfacing that big brand ads were
appearing against isis videos
after this one by one large advertisers
began to leave youtube as it was seen as
a racist terrorist breeding ground
this caused other large advertisers to
feel the pressure if they didn't join
the boycott
the theories as to the real motives of
the boycott are still debated
but some think that it was just an
excuse to cut costs because profits were
down globally
others say that it was just an effort by
the mainstream media
to drag youtube down along with their
dying legacy
regardless of the real motives 750
million dollars has already been lost
and this will turn into billions of
dollars being lost for youtube over the
coming years
without advertisers youtube couldn't
exist those expensive servers aren't
going to pay for themselves
so youtube had to do something the
solution
increase filtering and modify algorithms
but this has come at a cost
some independent youtube news outlets
have been demonetized for having views
that don't seem to line up with the
accepted mainstream narrative
this has been done under the guise of
being too controversial
some people have viewed this as indirect
censorship
it even goes wider reaching than this
one of my favorite channels
h3h3 has been hit pretty badly with this
these policy changes in youtube stifle
the art of comedy in a way that's
reminiscent of radical political
correctness
if this keeps going eventually nobody's
going to be able to have an opinion on
youtube
in my view i think it's not really
youtube's fault youtube is just trying
to survive it's more the advertisers
that are out of touch
this could go two ways either the
creativity keeps getting stifled on
youtube and it becomes a shell of its
former self
or if youtube plays his cards right and
manages to fix this situation
this advertiser controversy could just
be a blip in the road
okay let's finish up on a light note
remember how the 2006 person of the year
on the cover of time magazine
was you well some people with a sense of
humor actually put this on their job
resumes so it read
that they were person of the year for
2006.
i stumbled across this in a reddit
thread and i found this pretty funny
one of the responses particularly caught
my eye
user bubba b writes i had it on my
resume while studying in new york city
for three years
2011-2014 i applied to 30 positions
during that time
went on maybe 20 interviews i had 10 job
offers
i accepted six job internships not a
single person
ever asked about it not once i brought
it to career counsellors
at one of the most prestigious schools
in the country and no one said a peep
i can't explain it i really can't so i
just thought that was something funny to
end out the video
i think looking back in a broad sense
with billions of people watching tens of
billions of hours of content every week
youtube is an incredibly impressive
achievement and i hope it sticks around
for a while longer
it's crazy that i've been watching
youtube since 2006.
i kind of grew up with it and i'm sure
many of you can relate
to have something like youtube ready and
available to all of us
is actually something pretty special so
that's it
that was just a bit about the origins of
youtube its size
and its impact on society today anyway
thanks for watching guys
maybe leave a comment about what your
favorite youtube channel is
if you just stumbled across this video
feel free to subscribe to this channel
for some more awesome content
this has been to gogo you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking
good
[Music]
you